Hola qué tal Buenos días desde lo
judicial todavía esta condena no está
firme en marzo de 2023 el tribunal va a
dar los fundamentos de la condena a
partir de ese momento tanto Cristina
Fernández de kirchner como los otros
miembros de de la de los acusados van a
poder apelar la sentencia en una primera
instancia y luego eventualmente ante la
Corte Suprema solo después de que la
Corte Suprema eventualmente confirmara
la sentencia algo que puede demorar
meses incluso Algunos años Luego de eso
realmente sería efectiva entonces esa
sentencia contra Cristina Fernández eso
desde lo judicial desde lo político se
abre todo un panorama Ella dijo en sus
reacciones que no va a ser candidata en
2023 Y eso era algo que estaba en el
aire se creía que podría eventualmente
haberse postulado tal vez a la
presidencia tal vez a senadora Pero dijo
que no va a estar en ninguna boleta Y
eso sobre todo abre el juego al interior
de su coalición el frente de todos para
quienes podrían ser los eventuales
candidatos en 2023 en la competencia
especialmente por la presidencia de la
nación en Argentina y también le pone la
ponen un lugar difícil a la oposición
porque cambia no sabe todavía con quién
va a competir al correrse la figura de
Cristina Fernández de kirchner Argentina
un año político que se va a poner muy
interesante en ese sentido en 2023 en
Argentina